still working on that afternoon almond
sucking on it so long it's smooth it's
like sea glass you do you
get that boy Ames
oops butter feed sorry about that sorry
bumbling son of a you just ruined
my life
hit by a truck and a dog takes a dump on
your face ain't nothing to see here just
a little hypoglycemic rage move along
I'm so sorry Hitchcock that's not me I'm
never like that that's okay it's my
fault I shouldn't bunch of cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot I hope
you've drown in a tub I hope you have an
aneurysm after an aneurysm after
aneurysm
don't make me get you again
um I'm building this dollhouse for my
girls it's their birthday tomorrow I
told my wife I'd get it done I'd seen
exact one when I was a kid
mom Charles is talking my dollhouse
grandma bought it for the both of us you
want some help big man no
I could do this
or it's just driving me a little crazy
where do I fix the princess Tower Boyle
where do I pay
attention
let it brother breathe
let a brother breathe
hey Sarge do we have any old t-shirts in
here
detectives ah captain did you come down
here to take a look at the two best
detectives you've ever worked with in
action the two best detectives I've ever
worked with are Montez and Dillman no
you've never mentioned that before they
were excellent I'm here because Major
Crimes wants this case I was hoping to
tell them you have some leads I
overheard you mention a Bilbo Baggins
should we bring them in well as much as
I would love to meet him he is not a
suspect okay so who is at this time no
one but we are currently investigating
no leads so you have nothing not nothing
Jake made a new best friend the vix mom
he promised her he'd solve the case
that's a rookie mistake okay fine so
maybe I'm not Montana and Dilbert Montez
and Dillman and they would have
remembered your name after one mention
because we're memorable and they're not
turn it around nope right look Captain
Rosa and I are gonna solve this case the
answer is in this room we just have to
focus and let the room speak to us isn't
that right room when you talk to the
room I lose even more confidence in you
why oh wait I see it all right can you
please just buy us some more time anyway
sir I feel like we've earned this
fine work fast you got it okay let's
look at the scene like we're seeing it
for the first time with fresh eyes Vic
was Face Down cast off splatter suggests
upward knife slices no signs of forced
entry laptop wallet keys were all there
doesn't kenota robbery wait a minute
have you said this already are we just
having the exact same conversation yep
cool moving on windows and doors locked
from the inside nobody in or out thank
you
think think oh the upstairs neighbor and
his best friend drill through the
ceiling murder atoms bleed all over the
apartment then climb back up and seal
the hole behind them negative we would
have found construction debris and
microscopic pain fibers the only thing
needs patching is that theory
okay new idea we're gonna get inside the
mind of the killer we eat the veggie
wraps
here we go
oh there's sick after
this is one twisted mother oh the beach
rock this guy is demented Rosa okay all
we have to do is figure out what kind of
person can walk by cameras without being
seen someone camouflaged as a wall
unlikely Harry Potter in his
invisibility clothes not a real person
doesn't exist what about a Looper
situation it could totally be a Looper
situation Looper situation my least
favorite hair
my God Rosa come here look at the blood
spatter do you see what I see uh blood
in the exact shape left Wayne The Rock
Johnson
big Samoan tattoo Rosa I think I just
made a connection the number three is
everywhere three people three types of
blood and guess what the tax was on the
veggie wraps three dollars
and 19 cents but if you ignore the 19
then it's three okay you've lost your
mind what who told you that was it room
no it's the fact that you think the room
has a voice and also you're working in
your boxers to
meet Rosa to beat the Heat we can't turn
on the AC that's not crazy it's just
smart Jake I gave the case to Major
Crimes what you can't do that I promise
now you can't let it go the scene's
yours guys
sorry Jake it's over okay Rosa fine
on room
you left your pants I don't care
you need to go to a hospital right now I
don't want to burst happening around me
it's way too gross I'm nowhere near
giving birth I haven't even lost my
mucus plug
out of you I'm sorry my baby grosses you
out Rosa I'm excited to meet your baby
when it's clean and wearing clothes and
not blasting out of you like some half
Cuban Jimmy Neutron I'm just at the
start of my labor your baby's coming
it's still not active labor don't worry
I'm not gonna have the baby here and get
placenta all over your desk or whatever
it is that you're afraid of but we'll
send us something that can get all over
actually technically you know what don't
answer that I don't want to know
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
Monkey haul me it's unbelievable I don't
need Monty Hall ruining my place of work
but Monty Hall has already ruined my
home life come on Sir the math thing
isn't the problem night shift's keeping
you and Kevin apart you two just need a
bone
what did you say
I said you two need a bone
oh
Dare You detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business
boom don't ever speak to me like that
again
why did you do that dude was pent up now
he knows problem solved
[Music]
just eating butter like a popsicle huh
yeah I know I'm spoiling myself but I'm
depressed or have you forgotten that
Jake my best friend is in prison wait
Jake's in prison yeah he and Rosa were
praying for a bunch of bank robberies by
Lieutenant Hawkins all right
and where's Gina our maternity leave we
were all at our baby shower last week
okay then why am I bleeding I don't know
Hitchcock oh so you don't have all the
answers I'm bleeding because my piece of
crap son-in-law bit me look we all miss
Jake and Rosa which is why we have to
keep working in case there has to be
some way to exonerate them I've been
looking but I can't find anything and I
don't know what to do I can't find
anything and I don't know what to do
title of your sex tape what is happening
right now they caught Hawkins trying to
flee the country she confessed to
everything and they let me out oh my God
Jake is it really you are you really
here you know it baby but first I gotta
hug my best friend welcome back Peralta
I just heard from the mayor to apologize
for what happened to you they're sending
you to Disney World you and one male
guest as long as I don't have to go on
any of the scary rides I just go for the
shows boil
were you dreaming about Jake again why
did you wake me up I told you never to
wake me up all right thanks
okay here's what Esther remembers about
the night that she was around she was
either at our restaurant or the movies
or doing something else and she was
either alone or with people the only
thing she was absolutely sure of is that
I seemed like a very nice boy which is
not relevant to the case but did make me
feel very good this is stupid it was 20
years ago no one remembers anything
I'm beginning to think maybe we should
climb out on that ledge and see how the
perp got in I was gonna say give up what
right after I came up with that
incredible ledge thing Terry 10 stories
up you can handle that search
scared of heights okay I'm scared of
bees I'm scared of snakes and I'm scared
that the Knicks might never be good
again but I am not scared of heights
[Music]
I would appreciate it